what's your biggest Market these days
like what do you know is like that one
market like no matter what they're
showing out for you well I say I would
say Los Angeles man and it's so big too
where you got you could do a show over
here and over here and over there and
yeah you do like You're Still rocking
there's so many little areas of La yeah
yeah a big market for me man so even
that with you know hooking up with the
ston for this video and everything
almost like showing love to to La too
you know um yeah of course he's a legend
yeah yeah for sure man and uh you know
talking about getting stuck like uh like
uh like it's a Friday you know in
traffic in La you know what I mean and
um you don't want to get stuck in life
like that did he direct the new video oh
yeah he directed the new video yeah did
you watch his uh Netflix documentary
that they about him in cartoon that [__]
was sick yeah do do do yeah cartoon did
these for me man the 12 did 128 yeah
that's how much was that did he did he
hit you like Peak Mr cartoon prices for
those uh I don't remember remember man I
think we were just [__] chilling and
listening to some moldies and having a
couple beers I feel like back then Mr
cartoon could have charged anything for
a tattoo rappers would have been like
yeah no I think he I think he hooked me
up pretty nicely man it was dope thank
you shout out to cartoon man what's up
shout out to Mr cartoon yeah yeah been a
minute been a minute for sure um ston
shot the uh the cover for neighborhood
music damn that's crazy that shot ass
that's back in 2004 man wow so we go way
back too you know way back are you aware
that like people kind of look at you as
like kind of like the the JayZ of Cho
rap do you like understand that like
that's like cuz whenever we think about
Cho rap like you are the god of it man
yeah no I mean I hear it man but you
know just just always just like going to
the studio and and uh doing my thing man
so that part doesn't really doesn't
really uh the noise and all the like
extra [__] doesn't really come across
your radar not really man I mean it does
it comes across my radar but I don't
really like it's kind of like deflected
kind of like a little bit because it
doesn't make doesn't do me I know I got
no opinion on it you know yeah man it's
a trip though but I don't look at myself
like that and I just kind of like and I
think maybe that's why the people dig
what I'm doing I don't know just kind of
works right I always wonder coming from
San Diego there is kind of like a weird
like rivalry between San Diego and LA
uhhuh but and and same thing with
Phoenix like Phoenix in La has this big
rivalry especially when it comes to
sports but like uh La is like always
embraced you always embraced magic in
such a crazy way for you like was it a
little harder for you to be a guy from
San Diego and break like up top in in LA
or or was it like pretty easy just
because of what you were doing yeah I
think it was pretty easy just because of
what I was doing you know yeah but uh a
big part of me when I first started was
uh and big shout out to Spanish flight
from the harbor area I would listen to
them man and uh and uh always dug what
they were doing with the all the samples
and everything um so I mean that's kind
of like where I started at so you know
big shout out to Al I was listening to
Al music already too you know yeah but
this is way back in the like 90 90 that
like 90 or something like that when the
Chargers moved to LA are you still like
a charger fan no I pretty much stopped
watching football man you were just like
when it when it was San Diego Chargers
that was one thing you know Los Angeles
Chargers then you got you know you got
other teams Los Angeles they don't need
I just be so heartbroken I couldn't
imagine like my football team leaving to
like a different city yeah but luckily I
wasn't into it that much to be like
heartbroken right right right it's just
like whatever so now now I just uh yeah
I don't watch too much P you got the
padr man yeah what who has the best
Mexican food San Diego or LA I don't
know but I'm like a taco shop type of
dude like the San Diego taco shops you
know yeah I I say it's I always tell
everybody the best Mexican food I always
look at proximity to the Border San
Diego's got the best Mexican food yeah
in my opinion I don't think it's close
and then it's
LA and other places yeah yeah that's I
would say I always say San Diego's
number one though yeah I would say that
too but like I said but I never I never
ate it everywhere you know you know what
I mean so I don't know you know if I
didn't hit the right place in LA or
something like that you know yeah just
like can't blame all LA or something you
know and the best food I've ever eaten
is in Tijana Tiana has the best [__]
Seafood I've ever had in my life get it
man do you ever like do you make it over
there to get like I haven't been over
there for a long time dude I used to go
to TJ when I was like 16 yeah I go I
don't I don't have health insurance so I
go over there and get like you know oh
yeah yeah see the dentist yeah used to
go down there man when my first uh
record came out over the night in the
619 and a Mexican gangster I was in ' 92
and I was out there uh outside of eloo
pub and you know passing out my my
records back then D I was 16 years old d
16 years old in TJ passing out your your
CD yeah my brother and then went up went
up into the show cuz uh there was I
don't I forgot it was performing that
night think was K Frost and I don't know
I don't know who it was but they all
went in but I was too young they
wouldn't let me in but I was passing on
my albums man damn so your first album
was 92 my first uh it's a single but
just over the s yeah so first time you
actually released any music releas
anything yeah 92 man that's crazy
cassette tape yeah and the record
longevity man yeah that's what I'm
saying man and you can't I mean I
couldn't plan for it just kind of
happened that way you know yeah but I
appreciate it and everything man so what
would be like you you said earlier that
you know you kind of went through your
spouts with the not showing up to shows
and maybe taking advantage of the [__] a
little bit yeah yeah yeah exactly for
any young uh upand cominging artists for
you know you've obviously kind of made
mistakes that you know maybe they can
learn from what would be some things you
would uh you would advise them to do I
made mistakes that I could learn from or
that I learned from and people other
people's made mistakes towards me that
that I've learned from you know what I
mean so it's uh you know never step on
nobody's toes don't burn no Bridges cuz
you never know man uh be humble but e
either you are humble or you're not you
know what I mean so you can't act like
you're humble you know uh either you are
you're not so um and uh just never never
burn nobody man because you just never
know man you know yeah yeah never burn a
bridge it's very important keep your
word and everything man always keep your
word you know and you're you were you
came early today and I was late so be
you know you know and and we're doing
this in the morning oh yeah yeah no for
sure man I was at nber Farm last night
till 2: in the morning so yeah I just do
him from Vegas last night you know and
then went to go eat over here at mama
how how Vegas is always a movie yeah
that was dope at the House of Blues at
the manday bay was it you magic uh bash
was someone else on magic bash jrocks uh
shout out to Jrock she's got a beautiful
voice yeah um I forget a couple others
but yeah I forget Sophia Marie you guys
are doing so many shows together have
you ever considered doing like a Best of
Both Worlds or like a a Westside
Connection type of album where it's like
you bash and magic and maybe it's like
10 songs they were talking about doing
some jams you know that would be crazy
we did a couple jams already me and me
and magic and uh we have one that's
coming out on uh on Magic album I guess
well you guys had did a record like
three or four years ago with that uh
what's that kid's name Oho CUO I was
going to say koku [__] but that song was
[__] raw yeah that went pretty big
man so that song was that was a
beautiful song yeah man that dude's sick
yeah yeah he's got a beautiful voice
that that's the thing too man I was
doing I did something for jrocks did
something for Spanish Fly Astic tribe a
little Grio from San Diego um who else
uh
uh uh Quatro presio the one for them too
go check it out that's a good one man to
abanda you know so shout out to you guys
too man um but uh I just got hip to a
new dude from San Diego have you heard
of him I think his name is little weirdo
uhhuh have you heard of him uh I heard
of him yeah yeah yeah he's pretty dope
yeah he's good he's good and then
there's um God damn it I can't think of
the kid's name what's the kid's name
from uh Oceanside that's doing the old
school Desi Hollow Desi hollow hollow
too man great guy yeah way cool man so I
liked what he was doing so he hit him up
but I've done so many features where I
thought maybe it was just time to do my
own you know what I mean yeah de's dope
man I like how he's kind of bringing
back that like G Funk yeah for sure man
yeah and he's younger like he like he's
just like paying homage like and he's
doing it in like a great Way's dope
super dope for sure shout out to
Oceanside man yeah for sure 760 in the
house Oceanside is like a place you
drive through on your way to San Diego
but you don't realize if you just get
off the freeway it's [__] gorgeous
I'll be driving through tomorrow you'll
be driving through no on Wednesday I'll
be driving through on Wednesday I'll be
driving through on Wednesday